[Musique]
pour le moment on était dans le people
au quiz tout ce qui se passe au niveau
des people il ya quelqu'un qui
critiquent beaucoup karine le marchand
c'est mathieu delambre karine lemarchand
leur vie de vider son sac ce soit joli
hâle a envie de vider son sac
regardez matthieu delormeau regardez
tout ce qu'il dit sur karine lemarchand
avantage c'est quoi bah monte à 6 1 me
lécher date alors que vous dit assumer
le parce que karina assume ce qu'elle
fait ce qu'elle dit merci mathieu et
chez les bodin's tu de l'omo un
animateur pour vous maintenant pour
matthieu karine lemarchand fausse elle
n'est pas très aimable avec le personnel
avec les salariés elle fait fausse
gentille tout cas un côté très
condescendant du coup dans cette
émission avec les agriculteurs qu'elle
en fasse vrai que j'arrive si bien payé
j'ai plein de fric vienne la ville et
jon hamm au cas où
c'est ce que je ressens personne ne voit
qu'elle se fout de leur gueule aux goûts
mais alors si vous avez un petit peu les
tomates ça se voit quelque peu
l'organisation jamais sera tirée par un
de ces garçons là ça se voit au 2e tour
brûle c'est dans ce domaine qu'il
maîtrise mal elle n'est pas journaliste
politique ne s'est pas rendu compte de
ce à quoi jouer les victimes du buzz
qu'elle a voulu fermer hier qu'elle a
voulu prendre
voilà alors non merci dont il avait la
charge
karine un petit rituel ouais c'est
karine vous êtes d'accord vous regardez
beaucoup touche pas à mon poste
et à chaque fois et vous en met plein la
gueule ce soir vous avez quelque chose à
lui dire
karine cet homme en sec le ton a changé
à partir d'une émission de tpm pays où
j'étais invité et je me suis mais qu'est
ce qui se passe là est en fait lors de
cette émission c'était le jour où on
avait annoncé que claire chazal quitté
tf1 est question parmi tant d'autres
cyril me dit est ce que tf1 a le droit
de vivre et claire chazal très bon bah
oui c'est une chaîne privée qui fait
quand même ce qu'elle veut avec ses
journalistes
et voilà ils vont apprendre à développer
sur ce truc là mais c'était mon opinion
à partir de ce moment là je suis l'objet
de ta détestation tu inventes des choses
sur moi parce que si on pose la question
année à des agriculteurs il serait quand
même comment répondre mais bon voilà tu
as inventé plein de trucs qu'importe a
le droit de ne pas aimer ce que je fais
tu as le droit de dire ce que tu veux
contre moi l'étape alors est d'inventer
des choses
donc je me suis dit bon je vais pas une
réponse ou tout ça ça glisse ainsi on a
peur de ce genre de remarque on arrête
ce métier tout de suite à la twitter on
arrête tout et en bon moi je m'en fous
en revanche j'aime bien savoir la chaux
des choses donc j'ai enquêté sur toi à
part à bord apparemment vous allez donc
intégré mieux quand on déteste à ce
point une personne ça veut dire que j'ai
touché ton coeur ça veut dire que
quelque chose chez moi à fait que ça t'a
ébranlé avec un et voilà merci et bien
sûr en amour et donc je me suis je me
suis renseigné auprès de toi et il ya
quelque chose qui revient toujours quand
tu perds ton temps tu parles de claire
chazal s'est tue dix jours elle est
comme ma mère c'est donc pas ouais non
mais j'aime beaucoup
tu dis j'ai pas je te jure je les
entends dire mais moins pour moi être
comme ma mère voilà et je sais que tu as
perdu ta mère et je pense que tu as fait
un transfert
on s'en est parlé une fois c'est
maintenant fait on s'en est parlé ya une
semaine dans une fête
j'allais devoir et s'était dit voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe comme tu avais un
petit peu bu et moi aussi
la plaie de la parole s'est délié est a
reconnu qu'effectivement ne supportait
pas que j'ai pu dire du mal mais j'ai
pas dit du mal de claire chazal
j'ai le droit de dire que dans ce métier
on a droit de partir moi meme je sui 1
je suis un je suis un objet de tu vois
de publicité quelques claret le jour je
marcherai plus on me [ __ ] à dehors
j'en ai conscience donc c'est valable
pour tout le monde et claire chazal elle
a pris la place de quelqu'un ça n'était
pas contre elle
je suis d'accord avec ce système c'est
ça qui nous fait bien vivre c'est aussi
parce qu'on gagne beaucoup d'argent
qu'on peut partir d'un jour à l'autre
toi tu t'es tu t'es focaliser sur moi à
cause de ça et depuis je suis un objet
des dvd des as de tessellation
c'est vrai ou c'est faux mathieu c'est
vrai non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai que ce jour là
la phrase exacte qui m'avait blessé
c'est comment je suis très ami avec
claire chazal elle s'est fait virer
d'une manière vraiment dégueulasse par
tf1 s'est fait marcher dessus par des
angles comme morandini ou d'autres qui
le détestaient c'est une femme qui a un
certain âge et qui ne méritait pas ça
elle a été très triste très touché par
tout ça et qu'on parte avec avec 2
euros ou avec des millions d'euros il
n'empêche qu'on peut être malheureux et
mal de vivre et c'est vrai que ce jour
là vous avez dit tu es tu as dit à
l'antenne ce jour là est ce que dit ya
plein de gens qui sont virés tous les
jours on n'en fait pas tout un drame et
moi cette fille je savais que la chose
elle était très touché par tout ça qu'on
disait beaucoup de même beaucoup de
bêtises sur elle des chaleurs incroyable
et ce jour là effectivement c'est mon
ami toi tu as des amis et je le sais que
tu défends moi c'est mon ami je l' ai
défendu mais moi quand je défends
quelqu'un c'est pas pour autant que je
vais attaquer ou inventer sur la
personne qui les aident je reconnais qu
après j'en ai fait une affaire un peu
personnel c'est vrai est-ce que tu
d'accord que c'est une question d'
immaturité quelque part affective je
reconnais qu après sa défaite à faire un
peu personnel
cette partie là je reconnais et est ce
que tu crois pas que tu aurais tout à
gagner de parler plus avec ton coeur
plutôt que de faire des fixettes sur des
gens et de dire ben moi cette personne
quand elle a dit ça elle m'a blessée
parce que voilà tout ce que tu nous dis
là et je pense que tu serais plus ou
moins tu passerais moins pour un con ça
se passe pour un con il va falloir va
falloir que tu le saches un moment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est vrai et pour trois secondes ce
qui est vrai c'est que il ya une semaine
il ya une semaine je un anniversaire et
je savais pas du tout et j'arrive à
minuit et tout d'un coup on n'était pas
nombreux à 20,25 dans le noir of it will
be tong chhor karine et du coup c'est
vrai qu'on s'est parlé
c'est vrai qu'on sait des choses plutôt
intime et plus confiance et que carine
même nom eh ben on est de dire et juger
remettent les dire à l'antenne comme ça
les gens le verront aussi et même la
conclusion ça a été et du coup tu m'as
dit on part dans quelques jours ce
qu'est ce que tu veux venir avec nous
c'est vrai ou pas si c'est vrai alors
touche pas je peux te rends pas encore
mais peut-être fin mars en moins d'un
vrai qu'avec tous savent husky de landes
vous avez vraiment les jeunes disent ah
non ne le dit pas alors qu'ils en
vendent le poteau 1-2 d'un ami gay
puisque j'ai beaucoup d'amis grand train
avec qui vous partez avec qui vous je
parlais des amis sériba voiture est
candidat vérité la vérité moi lâche
maintenant alors attends je finis
[Applaudissements]
ça va être une autre limonade je ressens
pas d'accord juste confirmé oui moi je
pense que quand on parle avec son coeur
et franchement je le fais aussi dans mes
émissions je le fais dans ma vie on a
tout à gagner et il faut dire ce qui
nous peine et ça nous évite de faire des
deux braqué comme ça contre des gens
maintenant moi je t'en veux pas ces jeux
de la télévision mais mais parfois tu es
une caricature de toi même et je crois
que ce serait mieux si tu étais dans
dans le temps ta vérité comme ça c'est
très honnête mais c'est très très bon
est-ce que tu as un truc à dire avec ton
coeur à karine est ce que ce que là je
crois qu'on tient fort mahon tient une
route d'un format est ce que tu leur as
tu vas 10 secondes pour prendre
l'adhésion est ce que tu as envie de
prendre karine dans tes bras vous faire
un gros câlin parce que je peux lui dire
en tout cas ce qui est vrai c'est que
c'est que je reconnais que j'ai dit des
choses que je ne pensais pas forcément
ce que je pense et je te les dix autres
soirs c'est que je crois que tu es une
des meilleure animatrice tu as la foi le
physique l'intelligence le talent
antenne vraie personnalité
c'est vrai qu'ensuite j'ai tapé beaucoup
parce que parce que tu m'avais fait mal
et que du coup lui quand j'aime les gens
je les défends kit est parfois un peu de
mauvaise foi ce que j'ai été et sur
cette partie là je m'en excuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]